[Musique]
pour
san isidro entre le mexique et les etats
unis est le poste frontière le plus
fréquenté du monde
parmi les voyageurs chargés de bagages
des ukrainiens ou des russes cherchent à
se réfugier aux états unis
vladimir à sa famille ont quitté
l'ukraine le 24 février aux premiers
jours de la guerre
nous venons tout juste d'arriver de
mexico nous avons fait plus de 11000 km
en avion
je me sens bien fatigué et nerveux
je suis triste à cause de la guerre en
ukraine
la famille a voyagé pendant 20 jours est
traversé six pays d'europe après un
départ en urgence
ce n'était pas facile nous avons
beaucoup pleuré
dans notre ville
bombardée deux aéroports
cette guerre a poussé plus de 4 millions
d'ukrainiens l'exil principalement dans
les pays limitrophes mais ils sont de
plus en plus nombreux à parcourir les
dix mille kilomètres pour rejoindre
tijuana
anastasia est accompagnée de son mari
américain elle a quitté sa ville kharkiv
quelques jours avant le début de
l'offensive russe
ma maison a été bombardée la maison de
ma grand mère a été bombardée
mon oncle est mort
il a été abattu par les russes après
quelques heures d'attentes les gardes
américains font signe au groupe de
passer
contrairement aux ukrainiens la plupart
des candidats à l'asile n'auront pas
cette chance nastia art j'aime leur fils
arrive de la russie voisine
nous cherchons l'asile politique aux
etats unis
nous sommes protestants
nous travaillons pour l'église
américaine en russie
nous sommes opprimés et considérés comme
des agents de l'ouest
impossible pour eux de passer la
frontière à cause du titre 42 cette
disposition empêche aux migrants de
déposer toute demande d'asile sur le sol
américain une loi adoptée il ya deux ans
pour éviter la propagation du coït 19 si
les ukrainiens sont admis aux états unis
pour raisons humanitaires
de plus en plus de russes se retrouvent
bloqués à tijuana c'est le cas d'agathe
à et sa famille arrivée au mexique il ya
plus de deux semaines
j'annoncerai ma mère je vois cette
frontière que je n'avais jamais vu avant
je trouve tout cela assez horrible tous
ces fils barbelés ont l'air si froid
ils empêchent les gens de fuir ce qu'il
doit fuir ce dont ils ont peur c'est
juste cruel
proche du leader de l'opposition alexeï
navalni la famille a préféré quitter le
pays face au durcissement de la
répression 6 h
après le début de la guerre en ukraine
la situation politique en russie s'est
détériorée
pourquoi la cagd à montlouis juste après
notre départ de russie poutine a signé
une loi qui prévoit jusqu'à 15 ans de
prison pour les personnes qui appellent
ce conflit une guerre morjane à lui dire
les associations d'aidé aux migrants
dénoncent l'injustice du titre 42
cela met en danger la vie des personnes
cela nuit leur droit à bénéficier d'une
protection internationale
ici le long de la frontière nous avons
des milliers de familles dans des villes
si dangereuse comme tijuana ciudad
juarez est innocent qui sont exposés à
de nombreux risques le mexique n'est pas
un pays tiers sûr
tijuana incarne depuis longtemps les
espoirs déchus de milliers de migrants à
la casa del migrante et honduriens
salvadorien a ici en mexicain attendent
désespérément de pouvoir déposer leur
demande d'asile etienne et hébergées ici
depuis trois mois et souhaite que la
solidarité envers les ukrainiens
s'étende aux autres
tournées dans le pays
et politique
depuis sa mise en place ou donald trump
le titre 42 aurait provoqué l'expulsion
de plus d'un 1,5 million de personnes